بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم السلام عليكم معكم
ساره عيز زعابي عمري 16 سنه راح احكيلكم
سالفه او قصه عن عصفوره كنت اعرفها وانا
صغيره كنت احبها وايد وكل يوم كنت اروح
لها اروح لها اقعد معاها اسولف معاها لكن
عصفوره هاي ما كانت مقتنعه بعمرها ما كانت
مقتنعه ان عندها شي جميل الا وهو الاجنحه
ما كانت مقتنعه انها تقدر تطير بسبب ان حد
قال حقها ما يستوي تطيرين وبعد لما ايجي
وقت الاكل ما كانت ترضى تاكل تقول لي ابى
خس ابى جزر ابى حلاوه اقول اقول حقها ما
يستوي انت عصفوره هالمره ردها فاجاني قالت
لي شو يعني عصفوره ما بكون
عصفوره رحت عنها يوم يومين ورجعت لها رجعت
ادورها ما حصلتها قعدت انتظرها حزنت بكيت
وقعدت افكر فيها اقتنعت بنفسها عرفت
بالشيء الجميل اللي
عندها وانا افكر فيها تذكرت شخص طفله
صغيره عمرها ثلاث سنوات تحب ترسم وتشخ بط
وما كان تشوف غير ورقه والوان وترسم وترسم
وترسم وه الطفله كانت شغوفه بانها تدش
المدرسه تبى تدش المدرسه وترسم وتقدم
وتعرض رسماتها للناس دخلت المدرسه كبرت
صار عمرها سنوات ودخلت المدرسه وفي قلبها
وفي
ايدها واحساسها مش تغفه انها شغوفه عفوا
شغوفه بانها ترسم وتراويح
للناس رسمت ورسمت وراحت لمعلمتها يلا
معلمه هذه رسماتي شاركيه في
المسابقه يلا خاص بالدش المسابقه لكن رجعت
لها رسماتها رجعت لها رسماتها اول
مره ما فهمت شو السالفه رسمت مره ثانيه
ورسمت وراحت لمعلمتها يلا معلمه شاركيني
في مسابقه رجعت لها رسماتها لكن مع رد
غريب رد غريب خلاها تحزن وتتضايق رد غريب
ويقول ما يستوي انت من ابناء المواطنات
ليش ما يستوي طفله ما فهمت ليش وليش ما
يستوي كانت تب تشارك هي بس كانت شغفه
بانها تشارك في
المسابقه قاعد تفكر وتفكر ليش ما يستوي
ضايج حست عمرها
غير حست عمرها غير لدرجه حبست نفسها في
دائره صغيره قاعده تلف وتدور تدور على
مخرج وتلف وتدور لكن في يوم اكتشفت انها
مش دائره وانها كانت
وهم
اوكي اسفه وانها كانت
وهم طلعت من ه الدائره او خلينا نقول راحت
بعيد عن عنها الوهم او طارت بعيد عن ه
الوهم لانها اكتشفت انها عندها اجنحه
وانها تقدر تطير لفوق شاركت باول مسابقه
لها ما فازت لكن كانت شغوفه ومتحمسه حماسه
لهال المسابقه هو فوز لنفسها فازت شاركت
بهال المسابقه مسابقات دوليه ومحليه
ومعارض لنفسها ومعارض لغيرها ومعارضه
عالميه ما بس وقفت
لهنا كانت عندها روح قياده تبى توصل صوتها
لفوق تبغى توقف على منبر كل الناس يقدرون
يوقفون عليه كل الناس يقدرون يسمعون صوتها
دخلت مجلس شورى الاطفال ومجلس شورى الشباب
والحين تكمل في مجلس شورى
الشباب وتكمل في مجلس الشورى الشباب واجن
حتها توديها لفوق وفي رساله في قلبها
رساله بتوصلها لكل الناس ان امكانيات هي
اللي تحدد هويتكم امكانيات هي اجنحتكم هي
اللي بتخلي تطيروا لفوق مثل ما طارت
هالبنت الصغيره من ذاك الوهم وهي واقفه
لكم اليوم بكل فخر تحق
قصتها
[تصفيق]
وشكرا
شكرا